el ejército ucraniano niega la versión
dada por el Ministerio de defensa ruso
tanto el portavoz de las fuerzas del
este de Ucrania que luchan en esta parte
del país como la viceministra de defensa
negado que las fuerzas rusas tengan el
control total de esta pequeña población
de soledad en el corazón del Don vas
nosotros estábamos esta mañana en la en
la ciudad de backmud que es realmente el
gran objetivo de las fuerzas rusas en
esta región y nos contaban que si bien
habían habido grandes enfrentamientos
esta mañana de hecho la ciudad estaba
calmada porque habían logrado hacer
retroceder a las fuerzas rusas de ese
ataque que hicieron contra la población
de bacmut nos contaban también que
siguen teniendo presencia en la
población de Soledad Aunque el 70% si
estaría en poder de las tropas rusas y
también ellos tendrían el acceso de las
dos grandes vías que llevan a esta
población famosa sus minas de sal el
ejército ruso ha dicho que esto le
permitirá rodear y tomar posiblemente en
un futuro la ciudad de Back mood y lo
que hace consolidar es totalmente rodear
esta ciudad que se ha convertido en el
gran objetivo de las tropas rusas en los
últimos meses sin ningún éxito y aquí lo
que nos dicen es que las tropas de Moscú
están buscando tener alguna Gran
Victoria o por lo menos estratégica
Victoria antes del aniversario de la
Guerra el 24 de febrero sin embargo nos
dicen algunas versiones que habría una
posibilidad de que el ejército ucraniano
se retire eso le dar eventualmente otro
nos dicen que no que van a luchar y por
retomarla vimos grandes unidades de
ejército viniendo hacia la zona del
donbas esta madrugada cuando veníamos
camino hacia aquí vía de la ciudad de
deni Pro así que por lo menos lo único
seguro en este momento que dicen las
tropas ubicadas en ese lugar es que
soledad todavía tiene presencia de
fuerzas ucranianas